the two individuals named by the police
and CPS are officers from the Russian
military intelligence service
today's announcement marks the most
significant development in this
investigation
we now have sufficient evidence to bring
charges in relation to the attack on
Sergey Emilia scribble and Salisbury if
either man travels to a country where
the eaw is valid they will be arrested
and faced extradition on these charges
we will not tolerate such barbaric
attacks against our country it's early
March 2018 and the quiet Wiltshire city
of Salisbury famous for his cathedral
spire and medieval past is about to
become the center of the world two
people a man and a woman are found
unconscious on a bench in the city
centre within hours the older man's
identity is revealed he is sergey
skripnikov
from britain's mi6 during the 1990s the
younger woman found slumped next to him
is his daughter Yulia visiting her
father from Moscow they are both rushed
to the local hospital
sadly in addition a police officer who
was one of the first to attend was seen
a respond to the incident he's now also
in a serious condition in hospital
scruple had come to the UK in 2010 as
part of a prisoner swap deal negotiated
between Moscow and Washington for years
had lived a quiet anonymous life in
rural South West England but now his
past had caught up with him he's very
nice gentleman very polite and whenever
I see I'm really happy to serve Him
samples are taken from the victims and
sent to the Ministry of Defense's
Science and Technology laboratories
better known
as Porton down it's just nine miles down
the road from Salisbury its proximity
feeds growing conspiracy theories
emanating from Russia and her allies
within days the scientists have a result
Sir Guy and newless [ __ ] have been
poisoned by Nava chock a military-grade
nerve agent invented and manufactured by
the Soviet Union 250 specialist
counterterrorism officers are assigned
to the investigation and the military is
called in to help
they must wade through thousands of
hours of CCTV footage and sweep an
entire city searching for any small
trace of this deadly nerve agent in
Brussels the Prime Minister and her
national security adviser set out
Britain's case to NATO and EU allies
Russia staged a brazen and reckless
attack against the United Kingdom when
it attempted the murder of two people on
the streets of Salisbury I'll be raising
this issue with my counterparts today
because it's clear that the Russian
threat does not respect borders and
indeed the incident in Salisbury was
part of a pattern of Russian aggression
against Europe and its near neighbors
from the Western Balkans to the Middle
East in New York Britain's ambassador to
the United Nations clashes with her
Russian counterpart in the security
council chamber if I may say so mr.
president I won't take any lectures on
morality or run our responsibilities
under such international conventions
from a country that as this council
debated yesterday has done so much to
block the proper investigation of the
use of chemical weapons in Syria and in
London Moscow's ambassador holds a
series of televised press conferences
repeatedly questioning UK intelligence
and suggesting competing theories of his
own we get the impression that the
British government is deliberately
pursuing the policy of destroying all
possible evidence
classifying all remaining materials in
making an independent and transparent
investigation impossible behind the
scenes the UK intelligence agencies have
been working hard to convince their
partners that Russia was behind the
attack it pays off on the 27th of March
in a coordinated wave of global action
25 countries expel a hundred and forty
two Russian diplomats in an act of
solidarity with Britain it is the
largest mass expulsion of diplomats in
history and a considerable victory for
tourism as government against the odds
Sir Guy newly scrip will recover and a
discharge from hospital in Salisbury
they are taken into hiding but Yulia
records a statement from an undisclosed
location it is the first and to date the
only time that we have heard from either
of them in the longer term I hope to
return home to my own country I wish to
address a couple of issues directly and
have chosen to interrupt my
rehabilitation to make this short
statement I ask that everyone respects
the privacy of me and my father we need
time to recover and come to terms of
everything that has happened I'm
grateful for the offers of assistance
from the Russian embassy but at the
moment I do not wish to avail myself of
their services
for weeks the case goes quiet until a
dramatic and sad twist
to local residents named as dawn Sturgis
and Charlie Rowley are found foaming
from the mouth at a flat in the nearby
town of Amesbury
tests confirm that they too have been
poisoned by Nava shock
the hunt is on to establish where and
how they came into contact with the
nerve agent and whether the city of
Salisbury is still at risk
it will late to come out that Charlie
Rowley found a discarded perfume bottle
and gave it to his girlfriend a last the
police have the weapon on Saturday the
8th of July only a week after she was
rushed to hospital
dawn Sturgis dies Scotland Yard
escalates its investigation as you were
all now sadly aware we have launched a
murder investigation after learning the
devastating news that dawn sturgis died
in hospital last night at 26 minutes
past 8 it is both shocking and utterly
appalling that a British citizen has
died having been exposed to another
shock nerve agent over the summer the
investigation continued but little new
information came out until yesterday
almost exactly six months after the
attack on the scribbles the Metropolitan
Police got a small group of journalists
into a locked briefing room and for an
hour revealed detailed information that
they had gathered the most significant
developments of the investigation so far
CCTV images a timeline and most
importantly for the first time the
identity of the two Russian suspects
believed have been behind the poisoning
Scotland Yard's named them as Alexander
Petrov and Ruslan basarov both men
traveled on Russian passports both names
are believed to be aliases in the House
of Commons the Prime Minister went
further
the government has concluded that the
two individuals named by the police and
CPS are officers from the Russian
military intelligence service
also known as the GRU so this was not a
rogue operation we will not tolerate
such barbaric attacks against our
country and together with our allies
this government will continue to do
whatever is necessary to keep our people
safe at 3:00 p.m. on Friday the 2nd of
March Alexander Petrov and Ruslan
basarov arrived at Gatwick Airport on
Aeroflot flight su-25 88 from Moscow the
suspects traveled by train in central
London first Victoria Station then
crossing town to Waterloo that night
they slept at the city stay hotel on bow
road in East London the next morning the
pair took the tube back to Waterloo and
caught a train to Salisbury police
believed that this was a two-hour
reconnaissance trip carried out at the
same time coincidentally as Ullaeus
[ __ ] Sergei his daughter arrived in
the UK from Moscow by that time though
Pech off and basha off of back on the
train to London arriving at their hotel
on bow road at five past 8:00 on the
morning of the attempted assassination
the two suspects made their way once
again to Waterloo station arriving at
five past 8:00 and bordering a train and
carrying a counterfeit bottle of nina
ricci perfume filled with the deadly
nerve agent Nava Chong
they arrived in Salisbury at 11:48 and
ten minutes later they were caught on
CCTV around the corner from Sergey
scribbles house having done a recce the
day before the two suspects would have
known exactly what they had to do when
they got here but they have entered a
CCTV black hole there is no camera
coverage of this close and that has made
the investigation much harder the pair
were filmed again just after 1 o'clock
on fish Aten Road close to the station
we know that Sergey scribbles car was
seen driving from Devizes road to the
town centre at 1:30 in the afternoon
parking at the upper level of the
Moulton shopping centre car park at 1:40
we don't know whether he and his
daughter at home or where they were out
at the time that the novel shock was
applied but the exposure to the deadly
nerve agent must have taken place
sometime between 12:00 and 1:30 because
the two Russian suspects left Salisbury
just before 2 o'clock in the afternoon a
short time later
thus cripples move from the middle pub
where they had gone for a drink and they
went to have lunch at CeCe's Italian
restaurant they left there at 35 minutes
past 3:00 in the afternoon CCTV footage
shows them shortly after that on market
walk just before they were found
collapsed on a park bench nearby
as emergency services down in Salisbury
were responding to the scribbles the two
Russians patch off and basarov had
arrived back in London they made their
way immediately to Heathrow Airport
passing through passport control at 7:30
in the evening they boarded Aeroflot
flight su-25 85 which took off for
moscow at 10:30 p.m. just nine hours
after the pair they've carried out their
deadly attack this is a sophisticated
attack you know taking place across
borders from one country to another it
seems highly unlikely that anyone who
was come here planning an assassination
for assassination would have done so in
their real names we have intelligence we
have good lines of inquiry to try and
establish who they are but I need the
evidence I need somebody to come forward
and give me their real names we now have
the names and photos of the two key
suspects and a timeline of their
movements the story is being slowly
pieced together and Britain's key allies
say they believe it but how much if
anything did President Putin know about
this assassination attempt did it go to
the very top of the Russian government I
think he certainly allows the GRU and
other aspects of his intelligence
network to take decisions that in his
view will punish people who have
betrayed the Russian Federation so
whether he knew about the specific
operation or whether it was just who
will rid me of this turbulent priest
sort of stuff I don't think it matters
unless the Russian government hands
Alexander Petrov and Ruslan Bashir off
over it is unlikely they will ever face
justice but their operation in late
March on the streets of a quiet
Cathedral City has had profound global
consequences there were last year's